foreign
[Music]
the Super Mario Brothers movie is
currently running in theaters and is
winning over fans the animation style is
particularly well received which is why
we would like to take a spoiler-free
look behind the scenes of the film the
movie's production was in the works for
quite a while the last time a Mario
movie was released was back in 1993
during the Golden Age of Nintendo's
world famous games and it proved to be a
huge flop the gloomy fantasy Adventure
looked more like a science fiction
Thriller than a fun video game
adaptation following this letdown there
was years of uncertainty about further
adaptations for the cinema Nintendo was
very hesitant about the movie adaptation
rights and wanted to avoid another flop
at all costs at the end of 2017 it was
eventually reported that Nintendo was in
talks with universal and Illumination in
regards to a film adaptation just a few
weeks later things got clearer and a
release date of 2022 was set which was
not that far off with the actual release
now at the beginning of April 2023 the
fact that the movie was produced by
illumination is not a coincidence the
animations Studio belongs to the parent
company Universal Pictures and was able
to achieve worldwide success with
Despicable Me and minions the entire
animation process was done at
illumination Studios Paris and it took a
little more than a year to finish as a
result most of the work was done last
October and those responsible were free
to start promoting the movie before its
release according to director Michael
jelanik the Technologies used for the
Super Mario Brothers movie were upgraded
so the lighting effects in particular
were raised to a new level in an
interview with animation magazine
directors jelenic and Aaron Horvath
described the movie style as
cartoon-like and semi-realistic at the
same time those in charge one to create
the feeling of a Big Adventure movie
where it's not necessarily clear whether
the characters Will Survive the
spectacle in order to achieve this a lot
of time was invested in the design of
the individual characters so that they
come across as being much more down to
earth compared to other cartoon-like
animated films Donkey Kong has been
given an almost complete makeover the
barrel rolling monkey has been reworked
since the 1994 video game Donkey Kong
Country and looks more modern now after
the international Premiere many critics
praised not only the clear Nostalgia
factor for longtime fans but above all
the film's visuals into which plenty of
time had obviously been put another
highlight is the movie score which has
been highly praised The Man Behind it is
U.S composer Brian Tyler who has a lot
of experience in the film business among
other projects he scored the Expendables
movies Iron Man 3 and Avengers Age of
Ultron and thus clearly has a background
in the action genre the choice of Tyler
is the person in charge speaks for the
fact that illumination definitely wanted
to focus on action work on the sound
design by the way did not begin until
after the animation was completed so
that the recordings with professional
orchestras begin at the end of October
2022. it paid off as the film offers
fans what they've come to love over the
decades a treasure Trove of musical
themes and sound effects anyone who was
still undecided about watching the movie
in theaters has now hopefully been given
a reason to go and see it particularly
viewers who are already enjoyed the
games in their childhood should get
their money's worth if you've already
seen the movie feel free to let us know
your impressions in the comments
[Laughter]
[Music]